There were several steps along the way.
I went to college at overland and Ohio
and after that I went to Boston and then
after a couple of years there I went to
Grad School in Arizona in Tucson at the
University of Arizona and I stayed there
seven years and I met a woman who is
entering the Grad program just as I was
leaving and she was from Pakistan,
her name's asthma.
Awesome.
Han.
And we ended up getting married and then
after staying another year in Arizona,
after her graduation was she,
we were both eager to go somewhere and
try something different.
Um,
she had just come into the country to go
to university and then Grad school,
so she wasn't,
you know,
it wasn't an immigration thing or
something.
So we looked around,
we applied for jobs overseas.
We ended up going to Morocco for three
years as English teachers.
And uh,
that was,
that was interesting.
Well,
my world view of the states has been
slowly changing over time,
but yes,
there is nothing like leaving the
country to help you look back and see
the country more clearly.
And there's nothing like living with
people who are quite skeptical about the
intentions of your country to make you
think about that.
Um,
however,
I have to say that I'm just on a
personal level both in Morocco and then
in then people are incredibly friendly
and hospitable and interested and kind
of this idea that they're all just
raving lunatics a like you see on the
cover of Newsweek
is simply not true.
It's a lie is a lie designed to make you
stay home.
And so yes,
many people have very strong opinions
about Israel,
Palestine.
They think that Israel gets billions of
dollars per year,
which it does,
and the Palestinians get nothing and the
it money is being used for repression
and so forth.
That's a legitimate political opinion to
have.
Does this mean that they walk up to me
and beat me up on the street?
No,
it does not.
And that I wish that,
um,
perception could change.